se ve en este vídeo es que todos nos
sintamos cómodos con la forma de
visualizar y de contemplar los números
complejos así que vamos a empezar quizás
ya esté familiarizado con la idea de un
número complejo vamos a llamar a este
número z que es la variable que vamos a
intentar usar para denotar a números
complejos y digamos que z es a más b y
por supuesto z es complejo porque tiene
una parte real esta es la parte real y
tiene una parte imaginaria
así que usando esta anotación en
ocasiones uno puede encontrárselo en los
libros como que la parte real de zeta es
que es una función que si tú le pones un
número complejo te arroja un valor real
que en este caso es su parte real que ya
denotamos con morado por otro lado
tenemos la parte imaginaria de zeta que
es lo que nos va a arrojar aparte a
partir de un número complejo nos va a
arrojar otro número real que es el
número real que define su parte
imaginaria en este caso sería la ley el
número b
eso nos dice que está escalado digamos
lo podemos representar por una
multiplicación con b en otras palabras
lo que quiero es que veamos que podemos
ver este número complejo en el plano
cartesiano déjenme pintarlos los ejes
perfecto eso es
ahora lo que tenemos en el eje x en vez
del eje x vamos a llamarle la parte real
y el en vez del eje y vamos a tener la
parte imaginaria o el eje imaginario así
que z si lo escribimos como a más ve y
lo podemos representar como el punto que
tiene a en su parte real y ve en su
parte imaginaria es decir que ocupa un
punto en el plano cartesiano que será el
punto a cómo ve este punto a b perfecto
y aquí lo marcamos es la coordenada a
como ve muy bien entonces lo
representamos como una flecha como un
vector en el plano y esta es la
representación gráfica de un número
complejo z que tiene parte real y parte
imaginaria ve ahora cuando lo dibujamos
de esta forma podríamos también
representarlo con coordenadas x polares
quizás si estás familiarizado también
con esto pero lo que lo que implica
representarlo
polares es que este vector hace un
ángulo aquí déjenme ponerlo con amarillo
tiene un ángulo fi que genera con el eje
real y tiene alguna distancia del origen
al punto así que si tú das un ángulo y
una distancia también podemos definir
este número complejo de esa forma de
hecho el ángulo es se le conoce como el
argumento y aire se le conoce como el
módulo o la magnitud o el valor absoluto
de este número complejo pensemos un
poquito más en esto cómo calcular y amos
r
bueno r pues es la norma de este punto z
1 o el valor absoluto la magnitud como
se calcula bueno en realidad tenemos un
triángulo rectángulo aquí
así que tiene lados a y b y la base la
base es ahí la altura es b así que
calculando r simplemente usamos el
teorema de pitágoras verdad
r será la raíz cuadrada de la suma de
los cuadrados es decir de a cuadrada más
b cuadrada
muy bien eso sería el módulo ahora el
argumento como como como calculamos el
argumento bueno pensemos un poquito en
esto tenemos b ya pensemos que función
trigonométricas maneja el la el cateto
opuesto y el cateto adyacente así que
escribamos este diagrama está el soca
tohá realmente nos quedamos con toda
verdad es decir la tangente del ángulo
relaciona el cateto opuesto con el
cateto adyacente como lo relaciona pues
simplemente es cateto opuesto que en
este caso es b entre cateto adyacente
que en este caso es ad así que si
queremos resolver quién es el argumento
pues utilizamos la función arco tangente
o la tangente inversa de b / a
ahora pongamos el caso contrario que
tengamos el argumento y el módulo iii
que era que queremos representar este
número como un punto en el plano
cartesiano es decir tenemos grave y como
conseguimos sus coordenadas cartesianas
porque hace este momento teníamos veía y
obteníamos a través de estas fórmulas el
argumento y el módulo pero cómo le
hacemos para ir en el sentido inverso
bueno si tenemos rf y queremos encontrar
el lado adyacente que en este caso está
dado un ángulo y la hipotenusa podemos
tener que el coseno del co seno de este
ángulo es igual al cateto adyacente
entre hipotenusa es decir a sobre r
a sobre él multipliquemos ambos lados
por r y finalmente tenemos que recoge no
de fin es igual
aa
muy bien haremos algo similar con be
pero ahora en vez de tener el coche no
vamos a utilizar el seno del ángulo que
es cateto puesto que es b sobre
hipotenusa que es r multiplicando otra
vez por r a ambos lados tenemos r seno
de fi igual a b
muy bien ahora como escribiríamos este
número complejos y ahí b
tiene esta forma entonces z sería igual
a que en este caso es r coseno de fi que
es nuestra parte real más y veces la
parte imaginaria que es r seno de fin
así que escribimos rs no decir por y por
y que es la unidad imaginaria ahora no
sé a lo mejor te salta algo bastante
interesante en este punto si ya has
visto la fórmula de hoy leer vamos a
factorizar r primero y nos queda r por
jose no decir más
vamos a poner y ahora adelante por seno
de fi seno de fi muy bien ahora aquí y
si esto si ya has visto otros vídeos de
las series de taylor y bueno otra otra
serie de vídeos en la lista de cálculo
pues en realidad lo que hemos visto
desde estos resultados que además a mí
me pone a temblar de lo emocionante que
es la fórmula de hoy leer pues
justamente es esta es esta cosa verdad
esta misma cosa es lo que ya habíamos
visto en los desarrollos en series de
taylor de otras funciones lo que ya
habíamos visto es que es coseno de x y
seno de x lo que nos da en este caso es
el ala y sí
muy bien así que z lo podemos finalmente
escribir como r por el ala y
correcto ahora hay varias hay dos formas
de escribir este número complejo
principalmente podríamos escribirlo de
esta forma donde tienes la parte real y
la parte imaginaria uex o escribirlo en
su forma exponencial donde tenemos el
módulo y el argumento el argumento el
argumento perdón está en la función
exponencial y que esta forma nos va a
servir mucho para encontrar raíces
posteriormente así que hagamos un
ejemplo digamos que tuviera yo se está
escrito en coordenadas cartesianas z1
digamos no sé z1 es igual a raíz de tres
sobre dos más más y vamos a dejarlo así
así
así que como calculamos vamos a calcular
su módulo y su argumento como lo
haríamos entonces el módulo
el módulo déjenme hacerlo así el módulo
de zeta 1 será la raíz cuadrada del
primero al cuadrado que es tres cuartos
verdad raíz de tres al cuadrado es 32 al
cuadrado es cuatro más uno más uno pero
déjenme poner este uno como cuatro
cuartos para poder agrupar así que nos
queda tres cuartos más cuatro cuartos es
raíz de siete cuartos que es la raíz de
siete sobre la raíz de cuatro que es 2
muy bien ahora vamos a encontrar cuál es
el argumento así que dibujamos nuestro
triangulito en nuestro diagrama déjenme
pintarlo incluso hasta con los ejes el
diagrama se vería de esta forma okay
estaría en el primer cuadrante pero no
tengo que preocuparme mucho de eso
déjenme dibujarlo
de esta forma ok entonces tenemos en el
eje x a tres raíces de 3 sobre 2 miren
déjenme cambiar esto un poco para que
sea mucho más fácil la forma de calcular
todo esto vamos a limpiar todo esto ok
perfecto vamos a hacer un ejemplo mucho
más sencillo así que en vez de solo
sumar y vamos a sumar un medio de ahí
entonces z uno va a ser raíz de tres
sobre dos más un medio de y así que otra
vez su módulo que va a ser la raíz
cuadrada del primero al cuadrado que es
tres cuartos más el segundo al cuadrado
que es un cuarto verdad un cuarto es un
medio al cuadrado ahora esto es la raíz
cuadrada de tres cuartos más un cuarto
que es uno finalmente es uno
ahora vamos a visualizar el argumento
tenemos nuestro eje imaginario
nuestro eje imaginario y ahora trazamos
nuestro eje real
esta es mi eje real vamos a colocar este
número complejo tiene norma 1 pero en su
en su parte real mide raíz de 3 entre 2
que es un poco menos que 1 verdad y en
su parte imaginaria mide un medio así
que si hay anda al 1 a candle un medio y
este punto es el que representa esta
flechita es la que representa
número complejo y tiene magnitud de 1
así que cómo le hacemos si tenemos aquí
el ángulo fi
ponemos nuestro triángulo y esta altura
será perdón o no a raíz de 3 sobre 2 es
un medio la altura muy bien ahora que lo
que tenemos bueno hay muchas formas de
hacer esto pero bueno podríamos
simplemente fijarnos en la tangente en
la tangente de un medio entre raíz de
tres sobre dos verdad porque tanto que
tangente de fi es un medio sobre la raíz
de tres sobre dos como lo vimos
anteriormente y utilizando las reglas
que ya conocemos para la la división de
dos fracciones tenemos que fi es la
tangente inversa o el arco tangente de
esta fracción que es 1 sobre la raíz de
3 verdad el 2 se cancela ahora también
podríamos ver que si es el seno inverso
de de quien como calculamos el seno de
fli pues es cateto opuesto / hipotenusa
verdad y el cateto opuesto es un medio
la hipotenusa es 1 así que sería seno
de un medio ahora también puedes
reconocer que este es un triángulo 30 60
90 es decir tiene ángulos 30 a 60 y
además el rectángulo al final fin
concluimos que es 30 grados
ok podríamos incluso hacerlo con coseno
en fin hay muchas formas pero lo que
queremos finalizar es llevar aquí en
términos de radiales y no de grados así
que si es igual a 30 grados que es lo
mismo que pi sextos verdad y sexos en
radiales son 30 grados ahora si queremos
expresar z uno de forma exponencial esto
sería lo mismo a que pusiéramos uno que
es la magnitud por el lápiz sobre seis
por y verdad y sobre seis es el
argumento y hay que multiplicarlo por iu
y con esto concluimos